-Sur ta commune,
il y a une augmentation du nombre
de familles monoparentales ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Et ça s'est fait petit à petit.
Avec tout ce qui se passe
actuellement,
avec toutes les crises qu'on a eues,
il y a des familles
qui ont "bien dérouillé".
-En France, 25 % des familles
sont monoparentales,
dont 40 % vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté,
contre 11 %
pour les autres familles.
Je suis Philippe Brun,
député de la 4e circonscription
de l'Eure
et je suis engagé pour aider
les familles monoparentales.
Femme
-Dans sa région d'origine,
au coeur du département de l'Eure,
tout près de Louviers,
Philippe Brun a été frappé
par le nombre important
de mères seules avec enfants
qui étaient impliqués
dans la révolte des gilets jaunes.
Aujourd'hui député socialiste,
il a décidé de chercher
des solutions
pour ces familles monoparentales
et il sait où rencontrer
certaines de ces mamans solos.
-Bonjour ! Ca va ?
-Bonjour !
Petit rire
-Ce jour-là, au Secours populaire,
on ne sait pas
où donner de la tête.
-C'est là.
-Voilà l'épicerie.
-On va laisser passer
notre Micheline.
-Laissons passer Micheline.
-Parce qu'elle est chargée.
-C'est pas trop lourd, ça va.
-Voilà les produits qui viennent
de la Communauté européenne.
Nous avons 216 familles inscrites.
Sur les familles monoparentales,
on en a 74.
-Sur 200... ?
-216.
-C'est énorme.
-Oui.
Par rapport aux autres années,
on a peut-être 10 % d'augmentation.
-Des mamans solos toujours
plus nombreuses d'année en année,
à l'image
de ce qui se passe
au niveau national.
La France n'a jamais compté
autant de familles monoparentales.
Il y en a plus désormais
que de familles nombreuses.
Mais surtout, ce sont elles
qui sont les plus pauvres en France.
-Il y a 10 ans, ces familles
n'utilisaient pas
le Secours populaire,
sauf pour les vacances,
mais pas pour l'alimentaire,
puisque ce que leur donnaient
la CAF et autres
leur suffisait pour vivre.
Alors que depuis le Covid,
on s'est aperçu
que ces familles avaient besoin
et donc elles reviennent en force.
30 % de familles monoparentales
sur un département, c'est énorme.
-Avant, avec 50 euros, je pouvais
acheter de la viande pour un mois.
Là, ça ne fait même pas
une semaine.
-Vous avez combien d'enfants ?
-Trois.
-Que vous élevez seule ?
-Oui, depuis toujours.
-Et vous touchez
une pension alimentaire ?
-Non.
En fait, j'ai essayé de travailler
au début, donc en intérim.
Donc à cette époque,
j'avais qu'un enfant.
Mais quand tu vois
que tout ton salaire
va chez la nounou,
c'est un peu compliqué.
-On est en train d'écrire une loi
pour donner un statut
aux familles monoparentales,
notamment aux mères célibataires
dont vous faites partie,
pour à la fois vous donner
davantage d'aides sociales
et un droit de priorité
aussi pour la garde
pour que vous puissiez bénéficier
d'une place en crèche
avant les autres,
pour que vous puissiez
plus facilement reprendre un emploi.
-Dans 85 % des cas,
ce sont les mères qui assument
les familles monoparentales.
Dans sa vie,
une femme sur trois
fera l'expérience d'être seule
en charge de ses enfants
au quotidien.
-C'est un combat à la fois social
et féministe.
Pour moi, c'est le premier
sujet féministe.
C'est le sujet
des mères célibataires.
Qui se battent au quotidien
et qui ne peuvent pas travailler.
Comme madame,
un tiers des allocataires du RSA
sont des familles monoparentales.
Cris d'enfants
-Problèmes de moyens,
problèmes d'isolement aussi,
car les mères seules portent souvent
une charge mentale très lourde.
Le risque d'épuisement est réel
pour ces mamans solos qui ont du mal
à avoir une vie sociale.
C'est pour lutter
contre cet isolement
que le vendredi soir, Djary Dia
organise des activités sportives.
-Cha-cha !
Musique dance
To the right.
Un, deux, un, deux.
Et on tourne.
-Ici, les enfants
sont les bienvenus.
-C'est trop mou, là !
On donne tout, là !
...
-Philippe Brun l'a soutenue
pour monter son association,
car la demande
est réelle.
...
-Bonjour M. Philippe. Ca va bien ?
-Ca va ?
-Ca va super !
-Y a qui comme entraîneurs ?
-Fabien ?
-Fabien.
-Les trois hommes qui sont là,
en fait.
Fabien, Neth et Michel, là-bas.
-C'est un club de Val-de-Reuil ?
-Oui, c'est un club rolivalois
qui s'appelle le Neth Gym.
Le souci de ces femmes-là, des fois,
c'est de dégager du temps.
Souvent, on a du mal à trouver
du temps parce qu'on a les enfants.
Le fait de participer aux activités
avec les enfants fait que
les femmes viennent.
-La question
des familles monoparentales,
on la réglera pas seulement
par des solutions d'allocations,
l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat.
Il faut mettre le paquet
sur l'accompagnement
à la parentalité
et donner à ces femmes...
à ces hommes aussi,
il y a des pères monoparentaux,
un peu de répit.
C'est du répit dont ils ont besoin,
de loisirs,
d'évolution personnelle,
d'épanouissement.
Et c'est ce que permet
l'association de Djary
et je suis très heureux
du travail qu'elle fait.
-L'association
ne fait pas qu'organiser
des cours de sport.
On crée aussi des groupes de parole
où on échange sur tout,
sans tabou, y compris
de la difficulté pour les mamans
d'éduquer seules leurs enfants.
-C'est vrai qu'on n'a pas de papa.
Y a personne
qui fait le rôle de papa,
On doit faire le papa et la maman
et on est des femmes,
on ne réagit pas de la même manière,
on n'a pas les mêmes émotions.
On n'est pas pareils donc...
C'est pas évident quand même
à tenir les enfants.
-Des difficultés qui font écho
aux annonces de la ministre
des Solidarités et des Familles.
Aurore Bergé veut imposer
des sanctions
aux parents dits défaillants
en rappelant que 60 % des mineurs
présentés à la justice
après les dernières émeutes étaient
issus de familles monoparentales.
-Ses paroles ont été difficiles
pour nous à entendre
dans le sens où nous sommes mamans.
Nous avons toutes
les responsabilités sur les épaules,
c'est pas simple.
Ces propos nous ont un peu choquées.
Dès lors que nous sommes
mères et seules,
nous sommes la cible de tout.
Voilà. On ne lui souhaite pas
de le vivre pour le comprendre,
mais aucune mère ne souhaite
que son enfant soit en échec.
-Quand ça commence à chauffer,
que la jeunesse se mobilise,
évidemment, on a beaucoup
plus de mal à retenir son enfant
quand on est au travail,
à temps partiel subi et de nuit.
Avec quatre
à gérer toute seule,
c'est pas facile de le retenir.
Mais stigmatiser
les familles monoparentales
comme ça a été fait,
c'est une erreur.
C'est pas en rajoutant une peine
à ceux qui ont déjà la double,
la triple, la quadruple,
la quintuple peine,
qu'on réglera le problème.
-En plus d'organiser
des activités pour les mamans solos,
l'association de Djary Dia
veut participer au débat
pour les aider financièrement.
Certes, une procédure toute récente
permet à ces femmes
de récupérer plus facilement
les pensions alimentaires dues.
Mais c'est encore
une femme sur trois
qui n'en touche pas.
La présidente de l'association
veut que le député aille plus loin
dans sa proposition de loi
afin que ces femmes
profitent pleinement
de ces pensions.
Et elle insiste sur un point
qu'ils ont déjà évoqué ensemble.
-Tu es venue me voir
il y a quelques mois.
La dernière fois qu'on s'est vus,
on a parlé
du problème
de la pension alimentaire.
Aujourd'hui, c'est la femme
qui reçoit la pension alimentaire
qui paye les impôts dessus.
Toi, tu en penses quoi ?
-Je pense qu'elle devrait être
défiscalisée pour ces femmes.
Pour mon cas,
je touche 120 euros par enfant
et ces 120 euros sont à déclarer.
Ca nous pénalise
dans le sens où ça nous fait changer
de tranche d'imposition,
en tranche au niveau de la CAF,
et donc finalement,
on n'y gagne pas grand-chose.
-C'est justement pour cette raison
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale,
dans le groupe de travail
transpartisan que j'anime,
on a décidé de porter la proposition
de défiscaliser
la pension alimentaire
et aussi de la retirer
du revenu fiscal de référence pour
le calcul des prestations sociales.
-Imposer la pension alimentaire
est d'autant plus incompréhensible
que les pères
déduisent ces sommes
de leur revenu fiscal.
-Bon, merci beaucoup d'être venue.
-Merci à toi.
-Le député socialiste va également
inclure dans sa proposition de loi
l'indexation des pensions
alimentaires sur l'inflation.
Une proposition
qui ne peut pas passer à côté
de la question du logement.
C'est la première difficulté
pour les familles monoparentales.
D'ailleurs, une grande partie
d'entre elles
vivent dans des surfaces
trop petites.
Philippe Brun rend visite
au maire du Manoir-sur-Seine
qui essaye de dynamiser
sa commune sans oublier personne.
-Bonjour Daniel.
-Bonjour Philippe. Comment vas-tu ?
-Alors c'est en train
de s'aménager ?
C'est sorti de terre.
-C'est ça.
C'est mon fameux projet
"Centres-Bourgs".
On essaye de faire une animation
avec les commerces, les logements,
les écoles, la crèche,
le Narval, la mairie,
l'agence postale.
Tout se passe là.
On espère que ça va avoir
beaucoup de succès mais j'y crois.
-Le centre névralgique
de la commune.
-Dans ce centre névralgique,
l'élu a voulu aussi
un immeuble de logements sociaux.
-Là,
il y a dix logements T2, T3,
sur deux étages.
-Sur ces 10 logements,
le maire a le pouvoir de choisir
les locataires de quatre d'entre eux
et il ne les a pas sélectionnés
par hasard.
-Sur ces logements-là,
on a priorisé
les familles monoparentales,
les personnes en difficulté,
c'est ce qu'ils ont.
Donc là, ça a bien marché
parce que j'en ai sur la commune.
Donc, ça s'est bien passé.
J'espère qu'ils sont contents.
Les logements que j'ai
pour la commune,
pour les familles monoparentales,
j'ai un exemple au premier étage,
où c'est une dame avec deux enfants
bien sûr seule,
et qui a une chance de travailler
pour la commune en tant qu'ACEM
à l'école maternelle à côté.
Pour elle, c'est bien.
Elle n'a pas de trajet,
les enfants sont tout près,
ils vont à la cantine,
donc elle peut continuer
à travailler et...
à faire le nécessaire
pour ses enfants
car c'est elle qui a la garde.
-Cette initiative
a le mérite d'exister,
mais pour P. Brun, il faut voir
les choses en plus grand.
Donner la priorité
aux familles monoparentales,
mais pas seulement.
-On veut créer un nouveau produit
de logement social
qui soit adapté
aux familles monoparentales
et qui permette aux communes,
aux bailleurs sociaux
de construire des logements
pour ces familles
souvent en grande difficulté.
On a auditionné des bailleurs
qui sont très intéressés.
On pourra mettre des familles
monoparentales ensemble,
avec parfois aussi des lieux communs
pour se rencontrer,
partager et vivre ensemble
cette parentalité nouvelle
que l'on vit seul.
C'est des lieux d'habitat partagé
qu'on essaie de développer
et c'est ce produit qu'on veut
faire passer au niveau législatif.
-Une initiative nécessaire
pour les deux millions
de familles monoparentales
car avec un seul salaire,
elles sont fortement discriminées
pour l'accès à la location
dans le secteur privé.
Philippe Brun devrait
présenter sa proposition de loi
en mars 2024
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Musique instrumentale légère
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA